examinateurs c'est pas un métier il veut
tout savoir leur ferme ils se donnent
même pas la peine d'apprendre le code de
la route enfin avec moi pas question de
passe droit premier candidat
bonjour monsieur monsieur vous vous
trouvez sur une route à grande
circulation n'est ce pas vous croisez
une route départementale dont la largeur
et double de celle d'un chemin vicinal
qui la prolonge au sud-ouest d'une ligne
médiane tracé par le bas côté d'une
route secondaire parallèle à celle comme
et d'éviter en empruntant le trajet
inverse de celui inscrit sur un panneau
indicateur placé derrière il pleut votre
essuie-glaces tombe en panne qu'a fait
de lui un je vous ai posé une question
précise monsieur je voudrais de répondre
oui bon vous ne savez pas eh bien vous
reviendra d'en prendre
je suis roquettes merci beaucoup oui
c'est celle dégagée parce qu'il ya
d'autres candidats
oui c'est ça
il va non ni la suivent un suivant
tous les papas l'homme asseyez-vous
notant qu'on a pierre montant dans
l'examen dans l'ancien ne soient les
animaux quand même
net
vous êtes bien installé ça va comme vous
voulez ben ça me gêne un peu les genoux
ah oui oui c'est une petite voiture wifi
chez des gros genoux les genoux la
prochaine fois on prendre un autocar
il ya intérêt parce que changerait pour
mes genoux bon monsieur première
question vous montez dans votre voiture
celle-ci ne veut pas démarrer que fait
tout ce que je veux ah bah vous feriez
bien le savoir vous montez dans votre
voiture elle ne démarre pas qu'est ce
que vous faites
ben je descends ah oui la manivelle
l'ange des 100 plus grands coups de
pompes dans cette saloperie de daniel
bien près d'ouvrir le capot ch - clé à
molette il classe les moteurs à milmort
soja prades jacob mais je suis pas du
genre à bessan merdé permettra de faire
un lien et puis pas par autre chose non
plus d'ailleurs
suis-je assez clair non autre chose me
suivre et à présent vous arrivez à un
carrefour
un agent de la force publique vous fait
signe de vous arrêter
qu'est ce que vous faites je pense
tu as passé que j'ai reçues sur le
buffet et au passage où ma foi qui régit
balance un bon coup de pompe dans la
poêle et votre avion
monsieur s'est pas appliqué à faire la
loi aidera prenez pas tout le siège
bon maintenant vous êtes sur une route
départementale rabat ça m'étonnerait
qu'est ce que vous dites j ça
m'étonnerait que choisit sur une route
départementale
j'y vais jamais sur les routes
départementales j'ai plein de boue et ça
sent mauvais j'entends bien monsieur
mais c'est une supposition vous êtes sur
une route départementale
non
je suis pas sur une route départementale
je viens de vous dire que j'ai maté
jamais les pieds sur les routes
départementales
j'aime pas ça les routes départementales
jeu et les routes départementales les
routes départementales rien que de mon
côté ça donne envie d'envoyer des
mandats dans la conscience claire me
menad mettra à mal faire
elle n'est pas mû gmail farcir la petite
asso co à à merveille vous commencé à
m'énerver avec vos questions après ce
que je vous en pose des questions mais
ce que je vous en cours est ce que je
vous demande qu'est ce que vous faites
il se passe aussi qu'est ce que vous
faites ici pas cela du tout parce que je
vous oblige à l'est sur une route
départementale avec ses chiens tout le
monde pourquoi vous avez 7 d'abrutis
ouais pourquoi ça ces abris les viêt ont
germé 1
la seule chose que je vous demande c'est
si vous me donnez mon père mais oui ou
non
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme temps
sans l'inviter à